Mhmmm, breakfast.
Nothing like starting off the day with some
whole grain oats, vitamins and nutrients.
I mean surely nobody has anything bad to say about the most important meal of the day!
Breakfast seems pretty non-controversial.
But ask someone who has it everyday to just
skip it?
Absolutely not.
Sorry, I like my English muffins.
Little bit of peanut butter. Tiny bit of honey. Sorry.
Besides, there’s all this news about how
breakfast is good for your health.
I mean, except when there’s all this other news about how it's not.
Now, most of these headlines claim to be based
on the results on scientific studies, so what’s
going on with this back-and-forth research?
The most recent study that headlines went
wild with claims that skipping breakfast leads
to heart disease.
The study examined the health and diets of
around 4,000 middle-aged bank workers….which
might be because a Spanish bank was partly
funding the study.
The researchers found that those who did not
eat breakfast had more plaque in their arteries,
putting them at higher risk for heart disease.
But, looking more closely, there are some
caveats to the study.
Like, only 3% of the participating bank workers self-reported as having skipped breakfast entirely.
Many of those studied ate a low-calorie meal
in the morning.
And all of the data was gathered by having
the participants self-report on what and when
they had eaten over the previous 15 days.
Now I don’t know about you, but I don’t even remember what I was eating at the beginning of this video.
Oh right.
Gross.
The lead researcher of the study also admits
that the results aren’t directly related
to eating breakfast per se.
It has more to do with what happens when someone
skips breakfast.
He said that skipping breakfast disrupts the
body’s internal clock, prompting people
to consume more calories throughout the later part of the day than they normally would.
But other researchers have said that there
doesn’t seem to be anything in this particular
study that provides evidence for that theory.
This of course is only the latest study to
examine the great breakfast question.
Researchers have been fascinated about our
morning eating habits for decades.
The first big study on the subject was carried
out in Alameda County, California in the 1960s.
Researchers documented the everyday habits of the county residents and found that eating
breakfast tended to be associated with improved
health and longer lifespans, as did getting
a good night’s sleep and exercising regularly.
And since then, multiple studies have tried
to determine if skipping breakfast can be
associated with weight gain and overall poorer
health.
But it turns out there is no conclusive proof
that this is the case.
For example, one recent study looked at the
eating habits of 12,000 Canadian adults, and
the conclusion was that "breakfast consumption was not consistently associated with differences
in body mass index or overweight prevalence."
So if you love breakfast, load up on the bacon and flapjacks.
And if you don’t, enjoy that sweet, sweet
20 minutes of extra sleep in the morning.
There is no real scientific proof to back
either lifestyle.
So you should probably ignore the headlines
and do whatever works for you.
Now whether you skip breakfast or not, you have to eat eventually, so check out this video
on the healthiest diet in the world.
It’s about way more than just food.
Be sure to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.